es klingt total verrückt aber es könnte
tatsächlich sein dass wir bald keine
sauerstoffflaschen mehr unter wasser
benötigen wie soll das gehen und können
wir auch flüssigkeit statt luft atmen
bord klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
vielen dank für diesen mega spannenden
dem vorschlag über whatsapp ja ein
forschungsteam aus dänemark hat ein
neuartiges kristall material entwickelt
das zum großteil aus kobalt besteht die
chemische verbindung namens aquaman
christel soll große mengen an sauerstoff
aus der luft aufnehmen können und bei
bedarf aber auch wieder abgeben das
metall kobalt führt dazu dass sauerstoff
überhaupt erst aufgenommen werden kann
auch im menschlichen körper der kobalt
im übrigen nicht selbst herstellen kann
spielt ist so eine wichtige rolle es
muss über atemluft wasser oder nahrung
aufgenommen werden aber nur in sehr
kleinen mengen
denn sonst kann es wiederum
gesundheitsschädigend wirken das
besondere das kristall gibt den
sauerstoff ohne druck oder erhitzung
frei dabei ändert sich die farbe ist das
kristall gesättigt mit sauerstoff ist es
dunkel blau bis schwarz wenn es den
sauerstoff abgibt färbt es sich rosa
dazu eine der beteiligten forscherinnen
christin mckenzie das material ist
sowohl sender als auch container für
sauerstoff wir können uns verwenden um
ihn aufzunehmen zu speichern und zu
transportieren
aufgrund dieser eigenschaften kann man
es als eine art künstliches hämoglobin
betrachten das dänische forschungsteam
glaubt dass die kristalle effektiver
sein als eine sauerstoffflasche
denn einige körnchen des materials
sollen schon den sauerstoffgehalt eines
mittelgroßen raums speichern können wir
genau bei tauchern eingesetzt werden
könnte das ist noch nicht klar
eine überlegung wäre die kristalle
einfach in den mund zu nehmen spannend
wäre das ganz natürlich nicht nur für
taucher sondern eben überall wo wir
menschen auf sauerstoff angewiesen sind
im weltall beispielsweise aber auch für
patienten die noch an sauerstoffgeräte
angebunden sind wäre dies eine denkbare
lösung auf den markt gebracht wurde das
sauerstoff kristall bisher allerdings
noch nicht eine komplett andere sache
die man aber auch aus science fiction
filmen kennt ist das atmen durch
verschiedene flüssigkeiten mit wasser
ist das nicht möglich dafür aber mit
flüssigkeiten in denen sowohl sauerstoff
als auch kohlendioxid sehr gut löslich
ist so genannte perfluorcarbon denn für
die atmung von organismen ist es nicht
wirklich wichtig ob flüssigkeit oder
luft geatmet wird hauptsache
es wird genug sauerstoff zugeführt und
kohlendioxid abtransportiert versuche
dazu gab es schon in den 60er jahren als
ein forschungsteam aus den usa mäuse für
mehr als 17 stunden in eine flüssigkeit
tauchten ohne dass die tiere erstickten
sie atmeten wirklich ausschließlich über
die sie umgebende flüssigkeit
mittlerweile ist die sogenannten
flüssigkeits beatmung auch wichtig im
medizinischen bereich beispielsweise bei
frühgeborenen babys mit unreifen lungen
oder auch patientinnen und patienten mit
akutem lungen versagen dabei werden die
lungen vollständig mit einer
perfluorcarbon flüssigkeit gefüllt die
durch ein spezielles beatmungsgerät mit
sauerstoff angereichert und dass
abgeordnete kohlendioxid entfernt wird
ich stelle es mir echt ein bisschen
spooky vor und zwar beide ideen mit
steinchen im mund und dann sicher zu
sein dass der sauerstoff ausreicht oder
die lungen voller flüssigkeit zu haben
und zu atmen ja mal schauen wann es die
ersten anwendungen für beide fälle für
uns otto normalverbraucher gibt so dass
wir das wirklich erleben können wenn ihr
keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen
dem verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei
whatsapp darum geht ihr die kaputte abo
boxee auf youtube und verpasst kein
video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
noch vor allen anderen also ich schicke
euch vorher eine nachricht vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks um social and
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus social media welt dafür da klicken
aber nicht die genau glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
drauf klicken können wir unsterblich
werden human enhancement bis dann bleibt
dran